[music playing]
I believe that this
nation should commit itself
to achieving the goal before
this decade is out of landing
a man on the moon and returning
him safely to the Earth.
NARRATOR: Four months after
John F. Kennedy was sworn
into office, he
promised that the United
States would put
a man on the moon
before the end of the 1960s.
And on July 20, 1969--
NEIL ARMSTRONG: That's
one small step for man,
one giant leap for mankind.
NARRATOR: But why was landing
a man on the moon so important?
When Kennedy made that
promise, the United
States and the Soviet Union were
at the height of the Cold War.
A major front in
that war was space,
and putting a man on the moon?
That would be the
ultimate victory.
On October 4, 1957,
the Soviet Union
had launched Sputnik, the
first artificial satellite
and the first man-made
object to orbit the earth.
ANNOUNCER: Today, a
new moon is in the sky,
a 23-inch metal sphere placed
in orbit by a Russian rocket.
NARRATOR: One month later,
they launched Sputnik 2.
The American press speculated
that these launches
gave Russia a military
advantage in the Cold War.
This marked the
beginning of what would
be known as the space race.
Feeling pressure, the United
States launched the Vanguard
satellite in December.
And after its launch
rocket reached
the height of a few feet,
it burst into flames.
Despite the slow start,
by the end of 1958,
Congress passed, and President
Eisenhower signed, the 1958
Space Act, which created NASA.
Both the US and the USSR created
lunar exploration programs,
each successfully launching
moon flyby missions in 1959.
But Russia led the space race.
In September 1959, Luna 2
became the first spacecraft
to reach the moon's surface.
On April 12, 1961,
Yuri Gagarin became
the first human in space.
The US was in dire need of
a win in the space race,
and it had to be something big.
So President Kennedy asked
Vice President Lyndon B.
Johnson to look into
what the US could
do to beat the Soviet Union.
Put a laboratory in space?
Orbit a man around the moon?
Land a man on the moon?
NASA's administrator,
James E. Webb,
said there was no way to beat
the Soviets in building a space
station, and the
Soviets could probably
send a man into the moon's
orbit just as quickly.
But maybe, just maybe, the
US could be the first to land
a man on the moon.
On May 25, 1961, JFK publicly
proposed that the US send a man
to the moon and return
him safely to Earth
before the end of the decade.
The effort to land
a man on the moon
was christened the
Apollo program,
and Kennedy predicted its
success would inspire people
worldwide to choose
American-style freedom
over Soviet-allied tyranny.
A few weeks later,
Kennedy, ever the diplomat,
met with Soviet premier
Nikita Khrushchev
and suggested the moon
landing be a joint effort.
But Khrushchev said no.
The Soviets deny that they
were trying to reach the moon,
but they were.
They built a moon suit
prototype and designed
a lunar module much like
their American counterparts.
Even though the Apollo program
was launched in the spirit
of competition, there
were multiple efforts
to diffuse the space race
for diplomatic reasons.
In September of
1963, Kennedy even
suggested that the US and Soviet
Union could still work together
on project Apollo, but any
prospect of cooperation
ended when he was
assassinated two months later.
Apollo became a memorial
to the fallen president,
and the space race continued.
Many firsts went to the Soviets.
The USSR achieved the
first long duration
spaceflight, the first
multi-person spaceflight,
and the first spacewalk.
In 1966, Russia pulled off the
first soft landing on the moon
with Luna 9, but they still
hadn't put a man on the moon.
On July 20, 1969,
the United States
did, only five months before
the deadline Kennedy had set
at the beginning of the decade.
On that day, the Apollo 11
mission landed two men--
Neil Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin--
on the moon.
They walked on the moon's
surface for over two hours,
and were then brought
safely back to Earth.
The US had finally
accomplished something
big the Soviets had not, and
set the stage for the future
of space exploration.